A fire of black disaster breaks out in the mountains of iron rust. A
dragon is coming. How can Baa keep everything from being destroyed? It's the
power of a loathsome dragon. But it's
strong, it has scales, it has a
huge
body, and it's an intelligent dragon called Barakia, who was born with the ability to manipulate words.
Power is
passed down to the gods.At that time, I fought against the god Eko, and
even Ekko was so hopeless.But I don't
like Ekko and the dragon.It's
scary.Don't be
scared.Here, there's
one more
on my armor.  What do you do with your hesitation to strike from scratch? You're even trickier than
Ururu. What's the matter? Should you surrender now? Or wrap your tail and run away?
You old man. You're
still trying to hit the nail on the head. That's just a
decoration.
Oh, it's easy to understand.  Either you just
cry and run away. Well,
if you don't run away, shoot harder and use more force. You're
so tired, Mel.